i
[Música]
las vacas derecha bajo las condiciones
de la ley marcial en unos minutos
firmaré un decreto de movilización
general y pediré a toda la población que
se una en torno al gobierno de arzak en
nagorno karabaj y armenia
[Música]
y tenemos una sola condición las fuerzas
armadas de armenia deben abandonar
inmediatamente y definitivamente
nuestras tierras con toda su fuerza si
el gobierno armenio cumple esta
condición no se detendrá la lucha el
derramamiento de sangre y se establecerá
la paz en la región
y el estallido de una guerra a gran
escala en el cáucaso meridional al borde
de la cual estamos ahora podría traer
las consecuencias más impredecibles
podría salir de la frontera de la región
y tomar volúmenes más amplios y amenazar
la seguridad y la estabilidad
internacional
[Música]
el actual estallido de hostilidades se
ha convertido en la consecuencia del
intento de armenia de descarrilar el
proceso de paz son declaraciones
incendiarias y belicistas y son
provocaciones constantes sobre el
terreno incluidos los ataques
deliberados de abril de 2016 y julio de
2020 o la incursión del grupo de
reconocimiento de sabotaje en el
territorio de azerbaiyán en agosto
la declaración infundada de azerbaiyán
tiene como objetivo ocultar su
responsabilidad por la agresión militar
a gran escala planificada previamente
contra el pueblo de nagorno karabakh el
27 de septiembre las fuerzas armadas de
azerbaiyán lanzaron misiles
aerotransportados a gran escala y un
ataque terrestre a lo largo de toda la
línea de contacto entre nagorno karabakh
y azerbaiyán
atacando asentamientos civiles
infraestructura y escuelas
[Música]
una paz duradera en el cáucaso requiere
de una retirada armenia de todo el
territorio azerbaiyano dividir bir zeit
[Música]
y anoche pude hablar con el presidente
putin sobre el tema y hace unos minutos
publicamos un comunicado conjunto
trump putin y yo mismo como los tres
copresidentes del grupo de mick
encargados de seguir la situación en
nagorno karabaj
exigimos un alto el fuego incondicional
apelando al buen sentido de los que
están empujando en distintas direcciones
para ir más allá de lo razonable excede
su equipo fue usted el proxy
el secretario general condenó el uso de
la fuerza y lamentó la pérdida de vidas
y el número de víctimas entre la
población civil el secretario general
instó enérgicamente a las partes a que
dejen de luchar de inmediato reduzcan
las tensiones y vuelvan a negociaciones
significativas sin condiciones previas
ni demoras orioles
[Música]